ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าคะวัน
นี้วันอะไรวันนี้วันจันทร์
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์ที่ 25
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
AE ผชอะไรคะปีพตต
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะมี 6
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
24 ค่ะเดือน
เมื่อเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตมีผช
2565 ปีค.ศต.ค.ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้
วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 26 ค่ะเดือนเดือน
เมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ครูฟ้า
10:00 น
10:00 นกี่นาที 4 นาที
10:04 ก็เป็นเวลากลางวันเป็นอากลางวัน
ก่อสร้าง
ประมาณเจอกับเรา 2 คน
วันนี้นะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะมีคำถามแบบ
น้ำเจ้าคำถามไหมคะก็ได้
ผู้หญิงก็เปิดแพนสกรีนสิคะผู้หญิงลืมทุก
ทีนะคะนักเรียนขอโทษด้วยค่ะถึงจะรีบปิด
ทำไมนะคะอ่ะอ่ะผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็จะมี
คำถามเนี่ยมาถามครูฟ้าแบบนี้อีกนะคะนัก
เรียนมาแล้ว
นะคะ
หาว
คำถามนะคะโอเคมองไม่เห็นนะคะนี่ค่ะคำถาม
ใช่ไหมมีคำถามสมาถามครูฟ้าลบออกก่อนนะคะ
ใน
เกี่ยวกับว่าครูฟ้าไม่มีอะไรที่เป็นของ
10 ยางนะสิบอย่างที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่มีถ้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่มีครูฟ้าจะรู้สึกบอกไม่
โอเคไม่ได้ขอของ 10 อย่างที่ปลูกรักคิด
ว่า
ห้องดีใช่ครูฟันขาดไม่ได้ใช่ไหมขายได้
ง่ายๆ
ไม่เอาเงินนะสมุดเงินใช่ไหม 100 บาทเนี่ย
หรือว่า US ดอลลาร์
เยนเนี่ยเงินเงินใช่ไหมเงินเนี่ยถ้าครู
หญิงกับกูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่มีเนี่ยไม่ได้แต่ว่า
เงินเนี่ยไม่เอาว่าทุกคนทุกคนทุกคนต้องมี
เงินใช่ไหมอาหารสมัยก๋วยเตี๋ยวส้มตำผัด
กระเพราที่เป็นข้าวเยอะนะคะก็
ฟังไม่เอาตะวันถ้าเป็นเมนูอะไรที่ครูฟ้า
ต้องกินความไม่ได้กินแล้วก็
เนี่ยโอเค
ของ 10 อย่างนะคะที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอาจไม่ได้
ถ้าครูฟ้าไม่มีกูฟังเจอ
ตายดีกว่าไอ้
จ่ายมีมีอะไรบ้างสวยของ 10 อย่าง
ได้
ให้ครูฟ้าจอดแล้วกันนะคะอย่างที่ 1 อย่าง
ของของอย่างที่หนึ่งที่ครูฟ้าขาดไม่ได้
ต้องมีให้แน่นอนว่าว่าอย่างที่หนึ่งนะคะ
ก็คือ
อะไรก็สับค่ะ
โทรศัพท์
หน้าโทรศัพท์โทรศัพท์แต่ถ้าครูฟ้าไม่มี
โทรศัพท์ฟ้าเท่ากับบริษัทที่ไหนที่ไหนไม่
โอเคใช่มั้ยไม่โอเคไม่โอเคกูว่าต้องมี
โทรศัพท์
ต้องมีนะคะโทรศัพท์เลยผู้หญิงล่ะฮะ
หนังที่ 1  1
แว่นตาค่ะแว่นตา
มันจ๋าทางผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ใส่แว่นตารู้สึก
แบบไม่โอเคต้องมีตื่นนอนมาเนี่ยก็ต้องหา
แว่นตาแว่นตาเหมือนใส่
อย่างที่ 1 ที่คุยถึงขาดไม่ได้แว่นสา
อย่างที่สองของครูฟ้าอะไรคะที่ครูฟ้าขาด
ไม่ได้
iPad ค่ะ
Technology
เป็นเทคโนโลยีนะคะเพราะว่าลูกค้ามี
โทรศัพท์เดี๋ยวกูพาก็ยังมีไอแพดสิบล้อ
แม็กเล่นบอกครูฟ้าถ้าครูฟ้ามีโทรศัพท์
แล้วไม่มีไอแพดโอเคนะ
ไม่ได้ไม่ไม่ได้เพราะว่ากูป่าวเนี่ยมี
ไอแพดใช่ไหมเราก็มีปากกา
ปากกานะครับปากกามันก็จะต้องวาดรูปไง
ให้แวะฟ้าเดินใช่ไหมเดินเดินเดินเดิน
ว่าเห็นวิวภูเขาก็จะแบบวาดรูปเออเพราะว่า
โทรศัพท์โทรศัพท์เนี่ยว่านรูปไม่ได้ไม่
ได้
มันต้องมีไอแพดสมัยหา iPad เนี่ยไว้วาด
รูปถูกต้องหากก็เลยมีไอแพดเห็นไหมครูหญิง
ล่ะคะครูหญิง
ไม่มีอะไรอย่างที่สองการที่ 2 ห่วงครู
หญิงก็คืออันนี้ก่อนเลยก็ได้ค่ะก็เป็นของ
กินเนาะกาแฟดำอันนี้เป็นกาแฟแต่ว่าเป็น
กาแฟดำ
ไม่มีนมหมอนมเนี่ยไม่มีนะคะกาแฟดำเนี่ย
ไม่ได้ถ้าคุณตื่นนอนมาไม่ได้ดื่มกาแฟดำ
สวัสดีค่ะคุณ
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้นะ
อาจไม่ได้ค่ะอย่างที่สามของครูฟ้าอะไรคะ
ขนมค่ะ
ช่วยกันและคุกกี้
อะไรก็ได้นะอันนี้ช็อกโกแลตนะคะเดี๋ยวฟ้า
เนี่ยต้องมีขนมขนมก็แบบช็อคโกแลตคุกกี้
เยลลี่
มาการองอะไรแบบขนมมั้ยอ่ะหนังเอ็กซ์ปาย
เวเฟอร์โคกไทยขนมนะคะหรือว่าพิงโกขนมหรือ
หลังเป็น snack อ่ะเออว่าต้องมีนะคะค่ะ
หนูไม่ได้ขาดไม่ได้ไม่ได้ค่ะไม่ได้งั้น
อ้ะ
ผู้หญิงหรอคะ
อย่างที่ 3 ของครูหญิงที่ขาดไม่ได้ก็คือ
น้ำแข็งค่ะ
เรียนเห็นมั้ย
คือ morning เป็นน่ะน้ำแข็งแล้วนักเรียน
นักเรียนเห็นนะน้ำแข็งอุ้ยขอโทษค่ะเสียง
ดังน้ำแข็งนะคะขาดไม่ได้ค่ะครูฟ้าครูหญิง
เนี่ยเป็นคนที่ไม่ชอบร้อน
หือนั่งดื่มกาแฟก็ต้องใส่น้ำแข็ง 1 ว่า
ดื่มน้ำก็ต้องมีน้ำแข็งเอาน้ำแข็งน้ำแข็ง
ไม่ได้ค่ะต้องมีน้ำแข็ง
หนาวก็กินน้ำแข็งนะคะคุณก็เลยชาร์จงาน
เนี่ยไม่ได้อย่างที่ 4 ของครูฟ้าราคะ
อย่างที่ 4 ของครูคว้านะคะก็คือ
อะไรคะ
หูฟังค่ะ
ไหนอ๋ออ๋อหูฟังหูฟัง
[เพลง]
หูฟังเนี่ยหูฟังเอาไว้ฟังพอดแคสต์ฟังเพลง
ฟัง YouTube ใช่ไหมฝาเนี่ยชอบฟังเพลง
ค่ะ
หากครูเขาต้องมีหูฟังค่ะ
ไม่มีไม่ได้ตายตาย
ตายตายนะฟัง
มีสีลานักเรียนนั่นแหละ
อ่ะของครูหญิงล่ะคะเท่าไหร่แล้วนะ 4 ของ
ผู้หญิงอย่างที่ 4 เนาะอย่างที่ 4 ของครู
หญิงก็คือยางมัดผม
นี้อยากยางมัดผมหวังว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยมัดผม
ใช่ไหมมัดผมก็ต้องมียางเอาไว้มัดผม
มัดผมเนาะครบอย่างที่ 4 ของครูหญิงที่ขาด
ไม่ได้ก็คือ
อย่างมัดผมค่ะครูฟ้า
จะอย่างที่ 5 ของครูฟ้าที่ขาดไม่ได้อะไร
คะ
กระดาษทิชชู่ค่ะ
เข้าไว้ไม่มีแล้วครูฟ้าไม่โอเคหรอไม่มี
ใครอย่าคิดอู้ไม่ได้นะครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องมี
กระดาษทิชชู่
เอ้าก็ครูบามีค่ะคิดถึงนะหาเวลากินขนมใช่
มั้ยงามๆกินขนมเนี่ยกินเสร็จก็ต้องมี
กระดาษทิชชู่ใช่ไหมนะคะกระดาษทิชชู่ H
มือ
เช็ดมือเช็ดมือเช็ดมือเช็ดมือ
ขวาก็เลยขาดกระดาษทิชชู่ไม่ได้ต้องมีต้อง
มีอะต่อไป
2  True หญิงชิ้นที่ 5 สมัยชิ้นที่ 5 ก็
คือผู้หญิงต้องมีน้ำหอมนะกัน
มีใช่ไหมน้ำหอมน้ำหอมน้ำหอมใช่มั้ยเวลา
ที่เปิดขวดไวน์แต่ไม่ออกทำไมยังเยอะอยู่
ในซักขาดไม่ได้จะไปแล้วก็ฉีด
แล้วก็
หอมนานน้ำหอมค่ะครูฟ้าผู้หญิงต้องมีขอให้
ผู้หญิงมั้ยฉีดน้ำหอมผิวสวยๆไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ไม่ได้อันนี้เป็นอย่างที่ 5
อย่างที่ 6 ของครูฟ้าอะไรคะ
ครีมทาค่ะครีมทาผิว
Theme ใช่ไหม
ไม่ได้เยอะครีมทาผิวกูฤทธิ์วัดทาตัว
ละทาแขนทาตูนใช่ไหมครีมนะฮะเอาไว้ทาแขน
แมททาแขนเออไฟฟ้าขาดไม่ได้ต้องมีทรีนถ้า
ครูฟ้าไม่ทาครีมโอเคไหมกูฟ้าไม่โอเคค่ะ
ต้องมีครีม
มาเขา
ไทยขาดไม่ได้ค่ะผู้หญิงล่ะคะตัวอย่างที่ 6
อย่างที่ 6 ของครูหญิงก็คือเสื้อยืดสีขาว
เนาะอันนี้เป็นเสื้อยืดนะคะเสื้อยืดเสื้อ
ยืดนะคะแต่ต้องเป็นเสื้อยืดสีขาวอันนี้
แหละเสื้อยืดสีน้ำเงินโอเคไม่เป็นไรแต่
เสื้อยืดสีขาวเนี่ยไม่ได้คุยต้องมีผู้
หญิงพ่อใส่เสื้อยืดสีขาวก็เลยหาดเสื้อยืด
สีขาวไม่ได้ค่ะต้องมีซื้อซื่อๆมากๆนะๆต่อ
ไปค่ะอย่างที่ 7 ของครูฟ้าที่ขาดไม่ได้
อะไรคะอย่างที่เด็ดของครูฟ้าที่ขาดไม่ได้
นะคะก็ซื้อ
ลิปติกโอ้ว
ทำไมอ่ะกูฟ้า
เอาปากใช่ไหมต้องทาแป้งแต่ถ้าไม่ทาปากไม่
ได้นะคะ
มันไม่
ครูฟ้าไม่ทาลิปสติกแล้วคุณหมอกูฟ้าวีดีโอ
คอลผู้หญิงดูหน้าครูฟ้าได้ไหมแล้วกูฟัง
ไม่ทาลิปสติกมั้ยไม่ได้งายฟ้าต้องมี
ลิปสติกใช่คือลิปสติกแล้วก็ลิปมัน
วันนี้รีบมันนะคะสุโคราช
ไปโคราชไหมคะนักเรียนเอ๊ยติดแบรนด์ไหมคะ
ฮิฟัน
มันจะเป็นลิปมันหรือว่าลิปสติกที่ทาแล้ว
มีสีครูฟ้าเนี่ยขาดไม่ได้ไม่ได้ค่ะครู
หญิงไม่ได้ผู้หญิงล่ะชิ้นที่ 7 ฉะนั้น
สิ่งที่ 7 ของครูหญิงนะคะก็คือถุงเท้านะ
คะถุงเท้านักเรียนเห็นนี่เนาะธแต่เช้านะ
คะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยชอบใส่รองเท้าเอ่อทุกคน
ก็ใส่รองเท้าเนาะรองเท้าผู้หญิง
ทุกคนต้องมีรองเท้าใช่ไหมแต่กูหญิงเนี่ย
ชอบใส่ชอบ
ชอบใส่รองเท้าผ้าใบรองเท้าผ้าใบเป็นยังไง
ไม่มีเลยอ่ะอันนี้ได้เนาะ
เนี่ยนักเรียนแบบนี้เนาะรองเท้าผ้าใบ
นะรองเท้าผ้าใบเนี่ยผู้หญิงชอบใส่เวลาใส่
รองเท้าผ้าใบก็ต้องมีถุงเท้านะผู้หญิงไม่
ใส่ถุงเท้าไม่ได้ก็เลยของอย่างที่ 7 ที่
ครูหญิงแบบขาดไม่ได้ก็คือคือถุงเท้าค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
ขอมีอย่างที่ 8 ของครูฟ้าอะไรคะพี่ขาก็
ไม่ได้
หนังสือค่ะครูฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสือ
ชัยวัฒน์ชอบอ่านหนังสือนะคะเราก็จะต้องมี
หนังสือ
หนังสือนะคะหนังสือเนี่ย ebook ก็ได้หรือ
ว่าเป็นหนังสือก็ได้อ๋อคืออ่านอ่าน
หนังสือที่โทรศัพท์โอเคอ่านหนังสือ iPad
โอเคว่าเป็นเล่ม
หนังสือเป็นเล่มก็ได้นี่มาดูก่อนขาดไม่
ได้ไม่ได้งานชิ้น 8 ใช่ไหม
อีกแล้วสิ่งที่ 8 ของครูหญิงเนาะหัวจริง
หนึ่งของผู้หญิงก็คือ
อะไรอ่ะมาสคาร่า
แต่ว่ามาสคาร่าเนี่ยปกติเขาจะปัดขนตาสมัย
แต่ไม่นะคะผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็จะเอามาสำหรับ
ปัดถ้าหิวหนาคิวเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยปาก
ถ้าไม่มีลิปสติกไม่โอเคผู้หญิงโอเคผู้
หญิงเนี่ยคิ้วคิ้วไม่มีหึไม่โอเคเพราะผู้
หญิงมีคิ้วหน่อยนะคะตัดหัว
ปัดปัดคิ้วใจอีกนะหักมาสคาร่าปัดคิ้วนะ
สำหรับผู้หญิงก็เลยขาดไม่ได้ไม่มีไม่โอเค
อ่ะอย่างที่ 9 คุณของครูฟ้าอะไรคะพี่ครู
Fast ขาดไม่ได้ก็คือ
การ์ด
การ์ดหมาย
คือมันเป็นการ์ดเนี่ยฮะหาแต่ว่ามันเป็น
ซุปเปอร์สตาร์ที่ครูพาชอบใช่ไหมกูว่าต้อง
มีการ์ดนะคะขาดไม่ได้นี่เป็นนั่งเล่นนัด
ซุปเปอร์สาดปลาดูการ์ดซุปเปอร์สาว
มีความสุขใช่ไหมในหาก็เป็นแบบว่า Super
Star ดาราภาษาไทยพูดว่าดาราน้องซุปตาร์ 1
ดาราที่ว่าชอบนะขาดง่ายๆค่ะคุยโอเค
ผู้หญิงเนาะอย่างนี้แล้วนะคะก็คือร่มมา
ร่มไม่กางนะนักเรียนนี้ร่มใช่ไหมคะร่ม
เนี่ยสาดไม่ได้ประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ร้อนมากๆเวลาเดินออกไปข้างนอกก็ต้องมีร่ม
จะมีร่มไม่ร้อนนะพี่ก็เลยอ่ะอาจไม่ได้รม
อ่ะอย่างที่ 10 นะค่ะอย่างที่ 10 ที่ครู
ฟ้าขาดไม่ได้อะไรคะ
อย่างที่ 10 ก็นี่คือ
พานมไข่มุกค่ะอ๋อครูหญิงเนี่ยกาแฟสมัย
กาแฟดำถ้าไม่ได้ดื่มกาแฟดำเนี่ยกาแฟกาแฟ
แต่ถ้าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าไม่ได้ดื่มชานมไข่มุก
ชานมไข่มุกไข่มุกชาติไม่ได้ไม่ได้ทานม
ที่ไหนแล้วนักเรียนของ 10 อย่างที่
ผู้หญิงยังพูดเลย
อะไรคะอย่างที่ 10 ก็คือยาแก้ปวดหนาเวลา
ที่แบบเราแบบอ๋อปวดหัวใจปวดหัวเนี่ยก็
ต้องมีพาราเซตามอลไทยลิ้น OS ไพลินใช่ไหม
คะนี้ก็จะเป็นยาแก้ปวดเนาะผู้หญิงแหละ
ครับไม่ได้นะคะเวลาปวดหัวต้องกินยาแก้ปวด
Smart ถามโปรดก็คือของ 10 อย่างนะคะเอา
ของผู้หญิงก่อนหนออ้ายฮัก 1  1 รอบแล้ว
กันนะผู้หญิงเค้าจะมีจะไม่ได้แล้วนะคะ
กาแฟดำ
น้ำแข็งน้ำแข็งน้ำ
หอมใช่ไหมน้ำหอมนะยางมัดผม
สีเท้าค่ะเสื้อยืดสีขาว
ร่ม
ยาแก้ปวด
มาสคาร่า
คิดว่าหมดแล้วนะของผู้หญิง 10 อย่างของ
ครูฝามีอะไรบ้างของผู้หญิงแว่นตาล่ะแว่น
ตาใช่ไหมขอบคุณค่ะปูปลาแว่นตานะมีสิ่ง
อย่างที่กูหญิงขาดไม่ได้
โอเคของครูฟ้ามีหนังสือ
หรือนะคะ
โทรศัพท์
iPad  4  4G
หูฟัง
ขนม 6
ครีมทาผิว
กระดาษทิชชู่ชื่อ
ลิปสติกและลิปสติกลิปมัน 9
รัชดารา
ค่ะนมไข่มุกชาไข่มุกนอนแล้วนักเรียนน่ะ
นี่ติดนะคะแล้วนักเรียนมีอะไรที่ขาดไม่
ได้นะก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอ
นี้เราสองคนก็แต่ก่อนน้อยเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]